les queues de millières france était
l'une des dernières grandes compagnies
aériennes ne pas avoir signé d'alliance
avec un autre nom du ciel mondial s'est
fait depuis ce matin la société
française a dévoilé un projet d'accord
avec la compagnie américaine delta air
lines un rapprochement qui existait déjà
sur le plan commercial mais qui pourrait
devenir une alliance mondiale englobant
d'autres compagnies des précisions tout
de suite avec jean bernard schmidt et
andré germain le pdg d'air france jean
cyril spinetta avait promis d'annoncer
un événement majeur
c'est chose faite puisque la compagnie
nationale a décidé de partir à la
conquête du monde
rien de moins en s'alliant au troisième
transporteur américain delta air lines
en faisant ce choix stratégique
air france s'adapte désormais au marché
international
le transport aérien mondial se structure
à l'évidence autour de quelques très
grandes alliances et la volonté commune
d air france et de delta et de
construire une alliance mondiale qui
sera en compétition avec les quelques
très grandes agences mondiales qui
émergeront dans les prochaines années
l'accord signé ce matin prévoit une
alliance pour dix ans et la mise en
relation étroite des réseaux et des
programmes de fidélisation d'air france
et de delta
ce rapprochement s'inscrit dans un
processus de grandes alliances entre les
compagnies internationales
plusieurs partenariats sont constitués
ou en cours d'élaboration au tour de
united airlines et lufthansa de british
airways et american airlines ou encore
de northwest et klm air france était
l'un des derniers grands transporteurs
mondiaux à ne pas faire partie d'une
alliance jean cyril spinetta a voulu
faire taire ceux qui parlaient déjà
d'isolement pour la compagnie française
au premier jour de l'été la chaleur et
le mistral dans le sud de la france sont
attisées plusieurs feux de forêt le plus
important s'est déclenché hier après
midi sur la commune de cotignac près de
draguignan dans le var
et il aura fallu plus de 15 euros 400
pompiers mobilisés pour maîtriser dans
la nuit l'incendié qui a ravagé près de
400 hectares de bois et de landes
jacques cardoze jean-françois de jean
piétine c'est un court circuit dans une
maison qui aurait provoqué ce sinistre
hier vers 13h30 un court circuit dû à
une pizza abandonné dans un four le feu
à d'abord ravagé l'habitation avant
d'entamer une course folle comme vingt
ans plus tôt l' incendie s'est propagé
jusqu'à détruire 400 hectares de pinède
autour de la commune de cotignac pour
les secours il a fallu faire face à un
vent de nord ouest
un mistral tourbillonnant on peut avec
certaines méthodes de réflexion essayer
d'anticiper l'avenir du sinistre à plus
d'une heure au plus deux heures afin de
déplacer notre dispositif au fur et à
mesure que le sinistre évolué
le centre opérationnel des
sapeurs-pompiers du var a mis en place
un dispositif impressionnant huit
canadairs et quatre hélicoptères
bombardiers d'eau
on travaillait jusqu'à la tombée de la
nuit des moyens aériens qui ont ensuite
laissé seuls les 400 hommes mobilisés
des représentants de l'office national
des forêts et des agents d'edf ont prêté
secours
c'est des manoeuvres de sécurité cet
après midi c'était pour les largages
d'eau les bombardiers d'eau y en a eu
qui ont été faites et la meute est
lancée pour pouvoir manoeuvrer
tranquille et pas avoir dès l'annoncé
qui t'appelle en effet c'est à dire vous
faites quoi ouvrir la ligne les lignes
nu qui passent là nous les mettre hors
tension
à peine revenu du kosovo le commandant
jean-marc courrier a dû combattre le feu
jusqu'au milieu de la nuit
mais à aucun moment les habitants de la
commune n'ont été en danger
des maisons se trouvent noyés dans la
végétation
forte heureusement et centre nombre
d'entre elles avaient bien débroussaillé
autour équipe qui n'a pas été
véritablement inquiété de ce côté là ce
premier gros feux de l'été aurait pu
avoir des conséquences graves car les
ingrédients du cocktail était réuni
l'exigence et vents violents
à l'assemblée nationale le débat qui
commence aujourd'hui sur les liens entre
le pouvoir et la justice annonce des
plus passionnés la ministre elisabeth
guigou dit vouloir rompre avec une
tradition de soumission des magistrats
du parquet mais de nombreux élus
redoutent ce qu'ils appellent le pouvoir
des juges
alors pour bien comprendre les termes du
débat voici quelques explications et
réactions recueillies par dominique
verdeilhan et andré schürmann elisabeth
guigou l'a toujours dit elle ne veut pas
être le ministre des affaire d'où sa
volonté de couper au maximum le cordon
entre le garde des sceaux et les
procureurs le rôle du garde des sceaux
et de définir les orientations générales
de la politique pénale
mme elisabeth guigou préconise
l'interdiction de toute intervention
dans une affaire particulière la
possibilité de saisir une juridiction
dans l'intérêt général par exemple des
affaires de discrimination raciale le
garde des sceaux devant ensuite présenté
son bilan au parlement pierre
méhaignerie l'un de ses prédécesseurs au
ministère de la justice avait préconisé
que les instructions individuelles
soient écrites et versés au dossier
je crains que la suppression des
instructions individuelles écrit donc
transparente donc versé au dossier soit
remplacé par un coup de téléphone qui
sont beaucoup plus opaque
les procureurs généraux sont au nombre
de 33 en france leur rôle est de faire
appliquer la loi de déclencher les
poursuites mais il avait dit goût
veulent leur interdire d'entraver les
poursuites ou de classer sans suite
les procureurs de la république sont
plus de 180 en france leur rôle mettre
en oeuvre les orientations générales
recevoir les plaintes et décider des
suites à donner
elisabeth guigou leur demande en
revanche de motiver les classements sans
suite
les avancées qui ne satisfont guère les
députés de gauche un mauvais projet de
loi qui part d'une mauvaise idée tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire qu'il faut
clarifier les rapports entre le pouvoir
politique et la justice
mais faire croire aux gens que
l'indépendance de la justice
c'est l'indépendance des membres du
parquet toute l'ambiguïté tiendra donc
entre le droit de s'informer entre
procureur est garde des sceaux et
l'interdiction de donner des ordres
l'art dominique verdeilhan le projet
d'elisabeth guigou c'est un projet dont
on parle depuis très longtemps et
aujourd'hui encore il n'y a pas de
consensus non parce qu'il ya au
ministère de la justice
des souvenirs qui fâchent souvenez vous
à la fin des années 80 une perquisition
au siège du rpt bas graco et du parti
socialiste avaient donné des sueurs
froides au garde des sceaux de l'époque
plus récemment l'épisode rocambolesque
de l'hélicoptère le ministère de la
justice en 96 avait employé les grands
moyens pour tenter de récupérer le
procureur laurent davenas sommets de
l'himalaya et de stopper dans le même
temps le dossier de madame xavière
tiberi plus jamais ça dit en substance
elisabeth guigou et malgré les blessures
et les cicatrices du passé qui ont
plutôt assombri l'image de marque des
juges et des politiques et bien le
projet de loi de l'actuelle garde des
sceaux ne fait pas l'unanimité tant chez
les magistrats que chez les députés la
droite dénonce je cite un texte
médiatique et hypocrite la gauche
plurielle craint de son côté que cette
séparation entre la chancellerie et le
parquet accentue la formation d'un
gouvernement des juges le dit jean de 10
juin dernier à matignon lionel jospin a
plaidé la cohésion de la majorité face à
cette réforme tout va donc se jouer
durant le débat parlementaire
les juges les procureurs eux se sont
fixé une règle appliquée la loi
merci
les enquêteurs belges affirment avoir
découvert l'origine de la dioxine qui
avait contaminé des élevages de poulets
la contamination proviendrait de
produits fournis par l'entreprise faux
gras à la société verte est un
responsable de fo gras vient d'être
interpellé perquisition a été menée il
ya quelques jours dans son entreprise
une entreprise qui recycle les graisses
d'origine végétale ou animale et cette
information coïncide avec la décision ce
matin de la justice de gants de remettre
en liberté les deux responsables de
l'entreprise flamande vers castres selon
leur avocat l'innocence de ces deux
personnes seraient désormais prouver la
sécurité alimentaire c'est justement le
thème choisi aujourd'hui par jean-claude
allanic qui pour sa rubrique science du
mardi va nous montrer les différents
contrôles qui sont mises en oeuvre pour
dépister les fraudes et les pollutions
accidentelles
le poulet belge contaminés à la dioxine
les fromages porteurs de la bactérie
listéria ou même les derniers déboires
de coca cola nous font comprendre
aujourd'hui l'importance de ces
contrôles faits par des scientifique en
france les pouvoirs publics disposent
d'une dizaine de laboratoires de
vérification ils sont gérés par la
direction de la répression des fraudes
visite du laboratoire de massy en région
parisienne avec vous jean claude allanic
et claude barnier un sandwich pas très
appétissant mais ici on ne s'intéresse
pas à la gastronomie mais aux bactéries
80 scientifiques travail de laboratoire
de la répression des fraudes de massy
près de paris
leurs tâches quotidiennes analyser tout
ce qui se mange et tout ce qui passe
dans nos assiettes avec un seul souci
préserver la santé du consommateur
une tâche pas toujours évidente quand il
faut traquer l'invisible comme par
exemple les bactéries listeria qui ont
été à l'origine cet hiver de plusieurs
intoxications graves
nous recherchons dans ce sandwich
bactérie listeria monocytogenes
c'est une bactérie pathogène elle va
entraîner chez l'individu des cas de
septicémie
des cas d'avortement ou des cas
d'encéphalite notre sandwich broyées et
transformées en bouillon de culture et
mise en études pendant 24 heures on peut
ensuite lire le verdict directement dans
une boîte de pétri et savoir à quoi on a
échappé bien par exemple sur ce milieu
de culture nous voyons des colonies
verda as entre noirs sont
caractéristiques de listeria
monocytogenes est ce là nous avons une
forte suspicion une suspicion qui
entraînera le retrait des autres
sandwiches et une forte amende pour le
traiteur dans cette autre partie du
laboratoire c'est une pollution plus
insidieuse qui est des bus qui la
présence de pesticides dans les aliments
en l'occurrence c'est du thé qui est
dans le collimateur les moyens mis en
oeuvre sont appel à une technologie très
sophistiquée et très coûteuse du typhon
généralement des appareils de combat tu
auras fille gazeuse couplée à des
spectraux de masse l'ensemble coûte à
peu près un million de francs avec cet
ensemble on peut faire à peu près la
majorité des pays qui utilisa en france
grâce à ses moyens on peut lire les
résultats immédiatement se piquent sur
l'écran c'est un pesticide dans cette
pièce aussi plusieurs centaines de
milliers de francs de matériel
cette fois pour rechercher des traces
d'étain et de plomb dans une conserve
les polluants qui s'accumulent tout au
long d'une vie dans l'organisme du
consommateur avec à la clé des risques
de cancer mais il n'ya pas que les
aliments les plus variés qui sont
concernés cela touche aussi les
assiettes
là il n'y a pas de dioxine dans ce
poulet n'est peut-être du plomb dans la
peinture est un vrai menu composé par
jean claude annick le fait est bien
fourni alors on l'a vu dans ses
laboratoires ont des pistes tout tous
les types de contamination mais bien sûr
les risques sur la santé humaine sont
bien différents oui alors entre la vache
le poulet à la dioxine le veau aux
hormones le fromage au listeria le
jambon nitrites les colorants les
antibiotiques dans l'arrêt parce que je
vois que ça me décourage donc yaya il ya
beaucoup de risques mais les risques ne
sont pas de la même nature en vain
serrier or ce qui est surtout grave
c'est lorsque naturellement il peut y
avoir murdoch ou de graves intoxications
or là ça concerne en particulier trois
maladies qui sont la listériose qui sont
la salmonellose et le botulisme et puis
aussi la la maladie de la vache folle
là il ya vraiment des risques
d'intoxication très très graves est et
demeure donc ça faut faire très
attention à tous ces produits à d'autres
risques qui sont liées aux doses qui
sont sûrs jt ou cours de la vie donc ça
c'est moins grave ça concerne le plomb
le mercure les antibiotiques les
pesticides on l'a faut savoir que ça que
ça s'accumule dans l'organisme
est ce qu'on risque basse et au bout
d'un certain nombre d'années c'est
d'avoir aidé des cancers de force que
d'une fois ce qu'un pas très agréable on
risque aussi de faire des résistances
aux antibiotiques et puis on risque
aussi on l'a vu à minamata au japon avec
des pêcheurs qui avaient été empoisonnés
par le poisson mercure là c'était ils
ont été paralysées beaucoup sont meurt
donc voyez que il ya des risques à court
terme des risques à long terme
par ailleurs on l'a vu dans votre
reportage des moyens mis en oeuvre pour
contrôler les aliments avec des machines
dont on a d'ailleurs du mal à retenir le
nom et il paraît également jean-claude
que l'on est sur le point de mettre au
point un véritable nez artificiel
oui alors là c'est surtout pour pour
améliorer la qualité des aliments pour
éviter les fraudes
et puis hop au mieux à cette qualité or
ce n'est vous le voyez donc jusqu'à
présent on sentait les saveurs et on
utilisait le nez humain mais le nul là
bas il est un peu subjectif alors
maintenant la cette machine là qui est
utilisé par l'inra à côté de
clermont-ferrand permet de détecter les
saveurs dans un fromage tout tout ce qui
compose toutes les molécules qui
composent les saveurs d'un fromage ou
d'un ou d'un saucisson et ça vaut
plusieurs millions de francs qui se
faisait entre les chromatographie en
phase gazeuse en face des guildes et
spectrographe et et compagnie tout ça
coûte très très cher et les
scientifiques ont du pain sur la planche
apparemment pendant quelques années
c'est le prix de la sécurité alimentaire
subit
merci jean claude mal tu lis que nous
ramène à ce sujet puisque les analyses
du laboratoire de bordeaux concernant
donc la sphère coca cola n'ont rien
révélé c'est ce que vient d'annoncer
bernard kouchner qui précise toutefois
que quelques boîtes reste consignées
dans le cadre d'une enquête judiciaire
suite au décès in utero d'un bébé de
sept mois dans la mer avait bu du coca
cola une affaire sur laquelle nous
aurons certainement plus de précisions
dans le journal de 20h
du basket à présent avec une victoire
mais à l'arraché l'équipe de france de
basket a souffert hier soir à toulouse
face à la macédoine en l'emportant par
seulement 71 points sur 67
mais l'essentiel pour les bleus c'était
de réussir leur entrée dans le
championnat d'europe grâce notamment à
leur meneur de jeu tariq abdul wahad
commentaires laurent de baisse
si la france gagne hier soir à toulouse
face à une équipe de macédoine
terriblement accrocheuse
elle le doit en partie à cet homme tariq
abdul wahad tellement rien dire du tout
c'est dire que cette victoire c'est de
moi c'est un autre match des
championnats d'europe faut pas trop
faire couler donc sûr sûr sûr le premier
match
fois qu'un match et joué dans l'armoire
et
juste se concentrer son prochain seul
joueur français à évoluer en ligue
professionnelle américaine de basket
ball
tariq abdul wahad a inscrit en première
période 19 des 42 points que l'équipe de
france comptabilisé au repos une
première mi temps où les joueurs
français ont semblé incapables de
maîtriser les tirs lointains des
remuants macedonian notamment du numéro
10 péters naumoski meilleur marqueur de
la soirée avec 27 points en deuxième
période et malgré une défense rigoureuse
des bleus témoin ce contre
extraordinaire de moustapha sonko c'est
encore le meneur de jeu macédonien
naumoski 6 à 2043 de la retentissante
sirène final donne des sueurs froides à
la france en décrochant l'égalisation 65
parties
dans les dix dernières secondes antoine
rigaudeau selle par deux lancers francs
la courte et laborieuse victoire
française 61 67
l'équipe de france a prouvé qu'en plus
du physique elle possède aussi des nerfs
d'acier pour confirmer ce bon départ
dans le premier tour du championnat
d'europe de basket
rendez vous ce soir à toulouse face à
l'équipe d'israël
et puis en football c'est la grande
saison des transferts le capitaine de
l'équipe de france didier deschamps a
décidé de quitter la juventus de turin
pour l'équipe anglaise de chelsea
montant du transfert environ 30 millions
de francs pour un contrat de trois ans
le public l'avait découvert dans le
huitième jour aux côtés de daniel
auteuil depuis pascal duquenne s'est
imposé comme un acteur comme les autres
après le cinéma il revient au théâtre à
partir de ce soir il est au théâtre de
paris pour un spectacle intitulé chant
d'émotion marie-jo jouant hervé pozzo
ont assisté aux dernières répétitions
qui avait lieu à bruxelles
je suis je crois un pays aux confins de
l'imaginaire où naissent parfois des
artistes hors du commun
pascal duquenne 27 ans est l'un d'entre
eux jaco van dormael le cinéaste belge
lui a offert le 8e jour avec daniel
auteuil et un prix d'interprétation à
cannes
pascal lui donnent son quotidien aux
émotions fortes et simple il adore la
scène elle lui a ouvert les portes du
monde partout voyage et enfin italie
portugal 1 ravalo parce qu'elles seront
tous les jeudis à l'atelier d'expression
corporelle des platanes à bruxelles deux
ans et demi de travail acharné avec les
amis pour un spectacle qu'ils viennent
de présenter envoi du valais c'est de
penser à toutes les bonnes choses qu'on
a vécu en guadeloupe elle vous a essayé
de l'exprimer vous même avec votre corps
quarante minutes de danse théâtre un
spectacle mise en chorégraphie par
eux-mêmes et marie-jeanne les 2e manon
du groupe
chacun a exprimé ses désirs ce qu'il
voulait montrer aux parents aux
éducateurs et surtout au public est là
qui disait moi je veux exprimer ma
colère mais que l'air par rapport à
plein de choses que je peux pas arriver
à vivre comme une personne normale ma
colère d'être handicapé on a parlé de
tout ça avec eux
et on en attend un peu être
je pense à quoi tu vas quand tu es en
train de danser aussi de vrais hommes
c'est dit
rencontrer l'homme
aujourd'hui encore à l'issue du
spectacle comme dans le monde entier le
public se lèvera émue pour applaudir de
vrais artistes venus d'un pays aux
confins de l'imaginaire à kaboul un beau
petit bonnes dames 1 nous luttons pour
l'intégration
on ne leur laisse pas faire des
spectacles pour cons et qu'on vienne les
voir par sorte de pitié en ont leur
spectacle doit être aussi bien qu'un
autre spectacle intéresse cannes malgré
les centaines de lettres qu'il reçoit il
ne se prend toujours pas au sérieux ce
qu'ils demandent c'est d'être sur une
scène avec fougue et ça nous invité
patrick timsit et robert fort et vous
avez vu le spectacle qui avait lieu hier
soir et encore ce soir alors c est un
joli spectacle
c'est un spectacle très émouvant et donc
il ya pascal duquenne et donc voilà on
l'a bien vu dans le sujet 1 c'est toute
une troupe en fait il ya deux spectacles
et ccc visuels danse théâtre c'est un
vrai spectacle avec des vrais artistes
d'ailleurs la chorégraphe joue avec eux
et et on assiste un beau spectacle
jean patrick timsit je crois que tout le
monde se souvient que vous étiez opposé
en justice avec un robert forêt avant de
trouver un accord et inattendue patrick
timsit oublier à l'époque prouver que
l'un de vos sketches n'avait pas de
véritable malveillance vis-à-vis à des
enfants trisomiques commencé tanger
cette affaire en fait pourquoi bien
d'ailleurs
bon dieu tête ont parlé oui on a créé
une association d'ailleurs je je
là j'ai repris l'objet parce que ça
s'appelle un autre regard
voilà c'est pas une association comme
vous l'avez dit dans votre petit chapeau
c'est un peu maladroite à dire que c'est
pour me faire pardonner
on crée pas une association pour se
faire pardonner mais au contraire pour
agir quoi c'est pas du tout passif quoi
monde ans maintenant alors tous deux
s'étaient opposés à un moment donné donc
est un peu justement montrer justement
qu avec une énergie comme ça sur la non
écoute la non compréhension quand vous
vous balancer une phrase est que des
gens souffrent et se manifeste est
manifeste et et que vous vous expliquez
vous apercevez que en fait c'est
simplement de la communication ça
s'appelle un autre regard c'est une
écoute donc c'est je reprenais l'objet
ça sera beaucoup plus simple comme ça la
prochaine fois dans votre chapeau vous
ferez cette association a pour objet de
changer le regard de la société ou et ce
sera dangereux et errants
voilà sur les enfants trisomiques par
les moyens de la communication ni agir y
compris avec des enfants eux-mêmes pour
afin de mettre terme à l'exclusion dont
ils sont victimes justement voilà robert
un revers forêt et vous êtes le père
d'un enfant très les prisonniers est ce
que c'est cette affaire ce qui vous a
opposé à un moment donné ce que ça a
changé aussi votre manière peut-être
d'écouté de parler de communiquer aux
autres ce que vous vivez moi je pense qu
a toujours eu un manque de communication
la société française du moins a eu un
manque de communication vis-à-vis des
enfants handicapés
elle est encore bloqué elle est là elle
a su faire sauter certains verrous dans
d'autres blocages telle loi tels que le
racisme ou quoi que ce soit il faut pas
oublier que le racisme existe aussi être
la différence des lits avec l'handicap
quoi donc ce qu'on va essayer de faire
avec patrick et toutes les associations
parce que notre association est pas
fondées uniquement faire une association
et justement on va mettre en relation
tous les gens qui se battent sur le
terrain en quelque sorte et on va
essayer de promouvoir tous ses enfants
dit handicapé par tous leurs meilleurs
côté sportif artistique artistique ça
peut être le théâtre comme on l'a vu ça
peut être la peinture ça peut être
beaucoup de choses de façon à séduire ce
grand public pour montrer que nos
enfants mais il ya des projets précis
déjà on nous en avant sur la sûr on va
certainement faire des spectacles pour
récupérer des fonds parce qu'il va
falloir conviviaux york
cette association est un prêt d'argent
ici pour vivre et on va essayer on a
quelques projets je crois que sur la
peinture il ya un projet wii qui rejoint
d'ailleurs les lapins turquie et qui
sera fait avec des artistes peintres
donc handicapés énorme handicap essaie
de mélanger justement sur la paix à
notre regard je crois que
ce qu'est ce qui est formidable là
dedans c'est que c'est le regard de la
société sur eux et le regard qu'ils ont
un sur nous aussi et c'est ça qui m'a
marqué le plus
et voilà pourquoi cette énergie voilà
pourquoi tout ça paraisse il est attendu
et si et si
voilà on comprend pas on est un petit
peu largué et puis tout d'un coup on
s'aperçoit qu'en fait il ya plein de
boulot à faire et que cette association
est au service des autres associations
voilà c'est pas une association est ce
que vous patrick timsit le l'artiste est
ce que vous allez faire quelques choses
concrètement un spectacle par exemple
ben je ferai partie du spectacle bien
sûr puisque on à l'aboutissement
effectivement ce sera ça donne un lieu
un spectacle y compris à des petits
modules à des petits reportages sur ce
qui se passe sur le terrain avec toutes
ces associations qui d'ailleurs ont du
mal beaucoup à communiquer entre elles
et effectivement je ferai partie de ce
spectacle il assume personnellement
quand vous écrirez prochainement des
textes est ce que vous penserez à cette
affaire ce que vous allez vous auto
censurés ou est ce que on continue à
rire de tout écoutez c'est comme si on
faisait jamais attention dans cette
question j'ai toujours l'impression
qu'on est est ce que vous allez faire
attention comme si on ne faisait jamais
attention je crois que tous les comiques
font attention je crois qu'il ya des
fois des maladresses et les choses qui
passent et qui passe pas voilà un qui
ose et portait donc y
c'est comme si vous disiez un pilote de
formule 1 est ce que vous avez pensé aux
freins comme si le frein était un
inconvénient le frein fait partie de la
voiture et la libre en musique alors je
penserai bien sûr que j'y prends sa
bulle puisque c'est une
c'est une c'est une c tu es un rendez
vous dans une vie c'est une étape c'est
c'est quelque chose qui vous arrive et
qui fait partie après de votre vie mais
vous y pensiez
j'y pensais déjà ces derniers moreau
perforé vous avez changé votre regard
sur patrick timsit parce que vouliez
vous en avez vous lu quand même un
moment oui je lui en ai voulu pendant
trois ans et demi mais bon j'ai
complètement changé
mon regard sur lui on est devenu un peu
amis tous les deux et puis c'est vrai
que j'ai rencontré un homme un être qui
est extrêmement sensible et comme il l'a
dit ça a été un problème pour je pense
de communication nous avons eu un
problème de communication
je rappelle peut-être le nom de votre
association s'appelle un autre regard et
on va vous donner l'adresse donc 6 rue
de l'arrivée 92190 meudon en région
parisienne on en parlait de musique à
présent puisque la fête était jusqu'au
bout de la nuit hier en france et dans
le monde il y en avait pour tous les
goûts hier soir à l'occasion de la 18e
fête de la musique seul bémol à ce grand
rendez vous musical et bien un temps
frais et surtout des concerts de plus en
plus professionnels qui laisse moins de
place aujourd'hui aux petites
initiatives spontanées
pierre-emmanuel dunod frédéric basket
vont se revoir pour la fête de la
musique
on sort du boulot on va bronzer
obtiendrez la recette est simple et
depuis 18 ans elle fait ses preuves tous
les 21 juin
l'important les merguez pour l'admettre
bah ouais c'est un bon temps
elle a fait partie de la vingtaine a pu
laisser bon
il en faut pour tous les goûts l'hôtel
matignon pour sa part accueilli à la
tombée de la nuit
la soprano natalie dessay et aux quatre
coins de france chacun a pu inventer sa
propre façon de fêter toutes les
musiques
ouais
même si les groupes amateurs sont
toujours présents on peut regretter que
ce soit les grands podiums comme ici
celui de la place de la république à
paris qui réunissent la majorité des
spectateurs
nous avons déjà dit la fête de la
musique est une invention française qui
a largement dépassé nos frontières un
nouvel exemple pour la deuxième année
consécutive la ville de new york s'est
mise au diapason
notre correspondant dominique derda avec
eux toute la nuit au rythme de
l'orchestré du bal
évidemment à new york on n'entend pas ça
tous les jours
la fête de la musique dans est ici qu'à
sa seconde édition et le moins que l'on
puisse dire est qu'elle n'attire encore
qu un public clairsemé ne croit me
mais le grand orchestre du bal à plus
d'un 45 tours dans sa musette et bien
vite ces américains venus en famille
commence à se prendre au jeu en français
a beau être un peu rouillé et même si je
ne comprend qu'un mot sur 20 avec toute
la passion qu'ils y mettent
on voit bien ce qu'ils veulent dire
on devine çà et là dans l'assistance que
certains comprennent mieux que d'autres
la poésie des tests mais tous peu à peu
se laisse porter par la musique est
gagné par la fed
tout le temps que la foule est en délire
et dans nos mémoires a démarré un
référent gagnent jamais un moment de
démarrer mais une fois qu'ils étaient
bien chaud
séparés par chicago avant-hier san
francisco après demain mieux que bien
des chanteurs hexagonaux le grand
orchestre du bal à travers l'amérique
exporte ses airs joyeux et ça marche ou
plutôt sa danse
qu'importe alors pour devant de la scène
ils soient nombreux ou si peu et trois
personnalités du cinéma cette fois ont
été décorés ce matin par jacques chirac
légion d'honneur pour michel serrault
l'acteur que vous connaissez bien
évidemment légion d'honneur également
pour l'actrice la très belle actrice
claudia cardinale louis jacques chirac a
d'ailleurs salué la plus belle italienne
arrête unis on a les mêmes goûts
et puis pour terminer légion d'honneur
pour le critique henry chapier que nous
saluons la bourse de paris le cac 40 est
en baisse de 0,65 pour sans nouvelles de
la météo avec patrice drevet dans
quelques instants
que de bonnes nouvelles ouais la fia 20h
vous retrouver benoît duquesne les mois
sont là demain 13h au revoir excellent
après midi à tous sur france 2 bien sûr
à deux marques
i
oui on vous l'a déjà dit nous l'avons
tous si vous avez bien entendu je
voudrais que vous me disiez votre
docteur madame vous savez qu'aujourd'hui
le crédit lyonnais accompagne une pme
sur quatre en france
oui c'est maintenant qu'il faut réserver
vos actions crédit lyonnais sa
privatisation a commencé pour réserver
vos actions vous avez jusqu'au lundi 28
et particuliers bénéficient d'une
réduction de 0,7 euro sur le prix de la
recherche du père rendre mon siège
nouvelle série climatisé seat fraîche
elle rafraîchit les âmes à la claire
fontaine
je vais le cristallin elle l'a défiguré
frêche c'est excellent christine ça
coule de source
36 17 academia en direct de votre
académie tous les corrigés du bac et du
brevet tous les résultats des examens
36-17 academia j'ai acheté plein de
bonnes choses
fitness fruits oui c'est nouveau
le team entité chez plaisir saga
délicieux mais tu sais c'est bon pour
man estime regarde c'est fitness et
fruits une délicieuse sélection de
fruits avec les bienfaits des pétales
fitness au blé complet coupé fitness et
fruits c'est un plaisir de garder la
ligne
vous pensiez que la chaleur de ces choix
de nos cheveux aujourd'hui grâce à mes
nouveaux shampooings et soins thermaux
hâtive jacques dessange
la chaleur fait enfin du bien
leur formule vitamines et se déposent
sur toute la longueur du cheveu
sous la chaleur du séchoir et s'activent
pour réparer et fortifier mois
électrique put ans les cheveux en plus
de tenue
nouveau shampooings et soins thermaux
active jacques dessange toute ma
compétence professionnelle pour vos
cheveux dit avant de prendre la route
vous avez pensé à faire contrôler vos
freins non eh bah alors allé chez speedy
le contrôle et devis sont gratuits
payants ce moment les phrases sont à
-25% et nous le changeons que le
nécessaire vu la première fois que des
problèmes de fuites urinaires ont
commencé
j'ai été bouleversé j'avais peur que les
autres le voient le sentent aujourd'hui
je me sens mieux libre a aussi discrète
qui ne s'inquiète habituel était déjà
beaucoup plus efficace contre les fuites
aujourd'hui la nouvelle ibra va plus
loin grâce à son système odeurs contrôle
qui limite activement l'apparition des
bactéries et donc des odeurs maintenant
je vis comme je veux nouvelle libre à la
double protection contre les fuites et
les audard rtl présente
dieu nous balade on a tous pour notre
première fois toutes les plus grandes
chansons d'amour johnny hallyday sur en
double cd un événement universal
toutes les tendances de la bourse
c'est le cotation directe
36 68 70 quand on fait un choix
conscient c'est parce qu'on ne peut pas
faire autrement
ils ont abandonné un travail perdu des
amis ou se sont retrouvés sur la paille
pour vivre pleinement leur passion
dès que je bouge de façon pour
l'étrangler rer je pense aussi à la
danse passion de la danse des serpents
du champ d'un club ou d'une star elle
leur a redonné une raison de se lever le
matin
mais à quel prix demain soir sur france
2 les invités fougue de jean luc delarue
répondent à la question faut-il tout
cédé à sa passion
bonjour à tous rebonjour même on n'est
pas bien là tranquille paisible avec
plein de soleil sur la france je suis
sûr qu'elle n'a même plus de soleil qu'à
tahiti on verra ça un petit peu plus
tard d'ailleurs il ya quand même
quelques nuages sur le nord des cumulus
grille mais aussi quelques belles
éclaircies toujours un petit peu de vent
dans la vallée du rhône du mistral qui
soufflera jusqu'à 60 kilomètres par
heure mais ça va se calmer peu à peu et
demain il y en aura presque plus en ce
qui concerne les températures elles sont
en légère hausse elles varient de 17
degrés jusqu'à 21 à paris au nord de la
loire et puis au sud de la loire est
bien de 21 degrés au minimum pour
atteindre 27 degrés à perpignan
marseille et même ajaccio le ciel pour
demain toujours beaucoup de soleil sur
les régions du sud attention sur les
pyrénées ça va charger un petit peu en
nuage et puis aussi quelques passages
nuageux sur les côtes de la manche et
des nuages d'altitude sur la vallée de
la loire également sur le nord-est du
pays
températures au lever du jour toujours
un petit peu frisquette quand même un
pour les t4 à 11 sur le nord est puis 5
jusqu'à 17 sur le sud demain après midi
là ils sont un petit peu plus normal
puisqu'elles vont de 18 de la au minimum
jusqu'à 21 à paris à strasbourg au nord
et au sud est bien de 22 degrés au
minimum jusqu'à 24 à lyon 26 à nîmes 27
à marseille et puis à bastia si nous
allions d'ailleurs du côté des
territoires et départements d'outre-mer
nous nous apercevions qui lie à
saint-denis entre 19 et 26 degrés c'est
assez peu nuageux mais à fort de france
où ça va jusqu'à 31 c trés nuage à
cayenne où ça va jusqu'à 31 degrés aussi
c'est très nuageux et à tahiti je vous
le disais tout à l'heure ça va seulement
jusqu'à 30 degrés mais je suis quand
même déjà pas mal et ses nuages eux
aussi très bonne après midi à tous sur
france 2 bien sûr vous retrouverez
isabelle martinez après le journal de 20
heures à très bientôt
le contrat de confiance les voitures ne
devraient pouvoir en changer comme ça
mais le crédit l'assurance tout ça ça
tombe pas du ciel
j'ai basé ma patience a inventé le pacma
1 le crédit 12 l'assurance tous risques
qu 1,3 une garantie danon valeur d'achat